today we'll be talking about the
programs the courses the offerings that
are available to professionals through
Stanford
and I
am joined by my colleague Petra parakova
so my name is PAX Hammer I'm the
director of academic programs so I
oversee those parts of the artificial
intelligence programs that are credit
bearing that professionals can take and
I'll be going into detail about those
and Petra do you want to introduce
yourself
yeah sure thank you so much Pax and
welcome everybody to our AI info session
I am the associate director of computer
science and AI programs at scpd and I'm
focused more on the professional and of
the portfolio and just to kind of give
you a little bit more context before we
dive into kind of to our major AI
programs we do have one big program that
is AI graduate program that Parks will
be talking to you a little bit more
about
um about all the specifics what does
this mean that I will be covering the AI
professional certificate program but we
wanted to kind of bring this to your
attention that these are not the only
things we are offering as part of a CPD
Stanford center for professional
development if you are new to the field
you don't have much experience with
computer science and kind of uh the the
prerequisites that we will be talking
about shortly there is Coursera machine
learning specialization that is a little
bit more introductory
we have building an AI enabled
organization which is focused more kind
of on the business and or kind of the
business related topics and we also have
courses like Ai and Healthcare that are
kind of specifically focused on the
healthcare industry so there's a lot of
things that are going on in the field
not just the two big things we will be
covering in this session and in addition
to that we totally understand that
sometimes kind of paying for courses can
be Out Of Reach or that you would like
to kind of first get an idea of what you
might be getting yourself into before
you enroll and we also have a lot of
YouTube lectures that we will be talking
about freely available on YouTube so we
do recommend that you go to Stanford
online YouTube page take a look we have
a lot of content available for free and
also we are trying to run a webinars
regularly also on the topics focus on AI
so you will be able to follow up on
those two but without further Ado uh Pax
will tell you a little bit more about
the kind of the AI graduate uh piece
package great thank you Petra and one
thing to note is this this this
presentation will also go on our YouTube
page and we'll also send a recording out
of it to all of you in about a week so
if you have to drop off you'll be able
to find it uh or you'll get get it sent
to you
um and the other thing I'll mention is
this is interactive so feel free we're
going to be talking about these programs
but we know there are always a lot of
questions so feel free to post those as
we talk uh Petra and I will try to
answer those that we can we'll stop and
and answer some of them we also have our
other colleagues who are here who are
who are answering those questions sort
of individually so if you see uh if they
may respond if we can't respond or if
it's a sort of a straightforward
question about logistics
so building on what uh Petra on what
Petra said I'm going to talk about the
AI graduate certificate so this is a
certificate that is available through
Stanford
uh it's it is a credit bearing
certificate so you're going to be taking
classes and I'm going to go into some
more detail but a high level these are
the same classes that are happening on
campus and you would be joining them as
an online student uh as you complete
those classes you get a Stanford
transcript uh if you uh were to be
admitted into a master's program at
Stanford that was relevant to this you
could transfer up to 18 of those units
that you earned as what we call a
non-degree student towards that master's
degree so at a high level these These
are the actual classes that are
happening on campus I'm going to go into
a little bit more detail about what that
means exactly but I I think it's
important to stress these are not sort
of this is not an extension program
these are the same courses that are
happening on campus and you're taking it
alongside the students
to build on another thing that Petra
mentions the YouTube content a lot of
these a lot of these courses
their lectures are available on YouTube
as well as their syllabi are available
publicly so if you look at any
individual course under this AI graduate
certificate there's a good chance if you
look at it in our site you'll see a
little uh area where it says course
materials and I should say course
website if you click on that it'll take
you to probably the most recent version
of that Course and there you can see in
many cases they'll have all the
assignments they'll have the schedule
they'll have uh they'll even sometimes
have example projects from past
offerings of the course it's a really
valuable place to go when you're
considering a course for the AI graduate
program or for the professional program
to get a sense of what's covered in
these classes and as I said in many
cases and as Petra said you can find the
lectures as well uh uh available on
YouTube so if you're very motivated and
and disciplined person you could go
through a lot of this material on your
own it is it is a lot of it is freely
available
part of what Stanford is trying to do is
just make this information more broadly
available and that's why we have so many
different ways of offering this
okay so the the core of what the program
requires that the the AI graduate
certificate requires is you have to
complete at least one of the required
courses which is the artificial
intelligence principles and techniques
uh or the machine learning class you
could take both of them but you have to
do at least one and then you complete at
least at most three electives uh and you
can see the list of electives that are
available there and and we are adding to
that and it's kind of a constantly
changing mix in terms of the electives
so that's at the core of what it is
um let me go into a little bit more
detail I already see some good questions
about eligibility and those kinds of
things I'll get into that in a second I
I do just want to emphasize you know
what the nature of the program is again
because it is it is fairly unique so
again it's the the actual Sanford
graduate courses right they're happening
on campus we uh we schedule them in one
of our rooms where we have technicians
who record those those lectures
sometimes they're broadcast live that
depends on the faculty Member's Choice
and then uh you would be enrolled in
that class you're following along like
every other Stanford you know all the
Stanford students you're doing the same
assignments you're held in the same uh
the same standards and you're you're
completing the same work
you would watch the lectures at your
convenience again following the schedule
you would join office hours available on
Zoom again not all office hours may be
available on Zoom but there will be some
that are available online there's
usually some kind of discussion forum
that's available and then most of the
assignments that are that you're going
to be submitting will be submitted
online anyway and a lot of the other
materials are already available online
and you would have access you would you
know you would have a Stanford email
Stanford login you'd be able to access
some of the electronic resources that
are available so you will be basically
an online student in an on-campus class
and that's important to emphasize
because it's it's it's a an opportunity
and also a challenge of this particular
program it's it's an opportunity because
it is exactly the same material again
this is the desire of Stanford to make
this this material available more
broadly to working to professionals
around the world it's also a challenge
because it means that you are an online
student it's in a class that also has a
lot of on-campus students and so there
are obviously challenges to that right
you cannot turn to the student sitting
next to you in class uh you may be in a
different time zone so it's it's
important to keep that in mind when
you're deciding to take a a credit
bearing class
um as I said before you you know these
are actual Stanford courses so you're
earning a Stanford transcript as you
take these classes you are giving a a
grade and then you need to earn a b or
better to keep taking classes uh through
as a non-degree student and if you were
admitted into a master's degree you
could trans you could transfer up to 18
of those units towards the degree
um
and and I see a question that the
timeline question about the total degree
it's 45 units uh for a master's degree
typically for a master's degree at
Stanford uh so that it's about a third
of the Master's Degree you could
complete as a non-degree student again
you have to be admitted into the program
and it's it you know so you there are
plenty of people who've completed as a
certificate as a non-degree student and
they don't end up getting into the
master's degree but you still have the
certificate you still have uh you know
you still have the the material that you
learned
so let me you know so if if I emphasize
there the ways in which it is you know
it is
it is the on-campus class there are some
things about the the broader
um certificate or the non-degree option
uh program that are flexible and so the
first is that you can enroll in any
quarter or courses offered I'll go into
the application again eligibility in a
second but uh you don't the applications
anytime there's a quarter a quarter
where there's a course that's being
offered online that you're interested in
you can apply and enroll uh at that time
now again your enrollment still needs to
be approved but it's very flexible about
when you when you apply
um
I'm emphasizing The Graduate certificate
here but you don't have to pursue a
certificate you can choose to just take
individual courses and you can take
individual courses outside of any
particular certificate so you're welcome
to take a course and they that's under
sort of the artificial intelligence
graduate certificate and then take one
that's say under Robotics and autonomous
systems or something that's completely
different so you have a lot of
flexibility in what courses you take you
don't it's not a program in the same way
a degree program might be
um and I did want to mention that there
are a lot of other courses outside of
the AI graduate certificate that are
adjacent or related to artificial
intelligence or are fundamentally about
artificial intelligence I'm calling out
here on the slide the Robotics and
autonomous systems as well as the data
models and optimization uh graduate
certificates which also have a lot of
important material that's relevant to
anyone working in that field
the other part that's really nice is you
don't need to be continuously enrolled
and what that means is is uh you know
any of you who did a degree program you
have to take courses every single
quarter you have to maintain a certain
minimum number of of units uh if you
don't you need to take a leave of
absence or withdrawal and this one you
could take a course in the Autumn you
could take winter off and then you could
take a course in the spring you could
take a course in the Autumn and then the
next Autumn and there are a lot of
students who do that who choose to take
one course a year maybe they don't even
pursue a certificate they're just they
have that time once a year and so they
choose to do this
if you are pursuing a certificate you do
need to finish that coursework within
three years so that's basically from the
time you take the first course that's
part of the certificate to when you take
that last course to count towards the
certificate that needs to be three years
but there's no
um but if you're not pursuing a
certificate there's no limit on just you
can continue to take courses as long as
you are being approved by the
Departments to take those courses
um
uh I see some good questions
uh I'm gonna so
I see some good questions about uh about
eligibility so let me uh
let me just mention here okay so there
are some there are some prerequisites so
what's going to happen and I'll go under
the application process in a little bit
more detail is you would apply part of
that application is your transcripts in
a short statement and then every time
you enroll in a class the the
Department's going to pull up that
application and they're going to review
it and as you take classes they'll
review your Stanford transcript as well
so you you're not admitted into a
program you're not admitted into a
certificate you're you have your
enrollment approved for every course
so these prerequisites are are broadly
speaking for the the whole you know what
what you would need at the bare minimum
to be successful
and and earn the The Graduate
certificate in artificial intelligence
but the individual prerequisite the
prerequisites for individual courses may
be different and again the prerequisites
for other programs or other courses may
be different and maybe less than this
but broadly speaking for um for the the
AI graduate program or graduate
certificate you will need a bachelor's
degree that actually is true across the
board for computer science classes you
need a GPA of 3.0 or better for your
undergraduate degree uh it may be higher
for some classes so for instance Aeron
astronautics I believe requires an
undergraduate GPA of 3.5
um and there are some Aeron astronautics
courses that are part of the artificial
intelligence certificate
in terms of coursework that you'll want
to have completed and probably be pretty
pretty up-to-date in or at least review
before you begin the courses will be
College calculus and linear algebra and
again multi-variable calculus so this
would be like a semester a quarter
beyond what would be BC calculus in the
states the AP you know the advanced AP
in the US you'd want a little bit more
calculus than that as well as linear
algebra
you're going to want probability Theory
they say basic probably Theory but for a
lot of them they do ask you to have
probability Theory and statistics that
kind of post-calculus probability and
theory and statistics so a more advanced
um and you're going to want to have
programming experience a lot of these
are in Python but it would be useful uh
to have other other languages as well
under your belt and it can vary from
course to course so there's a lot there
this is not an introductory program
these are graduate level computer
science electrical engineering and air
on astronautics and other and statistics
courses so they are Advanced courses
um and and they're they're quite hard I
mean that's the other thing uh to note
is when you jump in to take these
classes any of you who have gone to
graduate school or have taken advanced
classes you'll know they can take 15 to
25 hours they're like a part-time job
they're very consuming very hard classes
and I think that's worth worth stressing
as Petra mentioned at the beginning
there are other things if you feel like
you're not quite ready for this or
um you you want just at the ground level
there are other things that we can
recommend through the stamp Stanford
online that would be worthwhile for you
to explore we do offer some of the basic
prerequisites through Stanford online so
we do offer math 51 which is basically
multivariable calculus and linear
algebra but you would already need to
have had you know single variable
calculus a year of a single variable
calculus and we do offer some courses on
probability Theory and statistics
so let me talk a little bit about the
application
um so it's it's a simple application
you're going to create account with us
you're going to submit that application
uh with transcription residency
documents so the key things here you're
going to have a statement of purpose
this is where you're going to explain
why uh why you're interested in taking
the classes it's also actually a useful
place to explain any uh any ways in
which you meet prerequisites that may
not stand out on your educational
background so an example is maybe you've
never taken a programming class in
college but you've worked as a
programmer for like 10 years because
you're self-taught that would be
something you could mention in your
statement of purpose uh then you you
there are some personal information and
residency status that we need uh then
you fill out your professional
experience a little bit like a resume or
a CV and then you you're you also fill
out your educational background Vision
to submitting the transcripts and then
at that point yeah once that's submitted
you can enroll in a course
um yeah you're anytime you enroll of
course uh it's always dependent on Final
approval from the Department as I said
what will happen is say after the
session you you're really excited about
it you say I'm going to go enroll in
deep generative models which is one of
the courses offered this fall you know
you meet the prerequisites you go you
fill out your application you submit it
we'll have your spot saved but and we're
going to send that application to the
department and there's someone there is
going to review it and say Yep this
person meets the prerequisites they're
approved to enroll in that course and at
that point your your enrollment would be
final uh and and you would you could
start taking the course
uh but there are many times when it's
it's it's it's not approved uh and that
can be because you don't meet the
prerequisites uh that's usually what it
is there can be other reasons as well so
I'll stop there um let me see other
questions here it looks like a lot of
these have been answered
um I think there was a question multiple
times that came up about what if I took
deep learning specialization machine
learning specialization some resources
from online courses that are not
necessarily degrees do they qualify for
as kind of a prerick visit for
understanding of the subject for
applying for the graduate program yeah
that's a that's a great question so uh
it it they could right that would be the
kind of thing you would maybe include in
your statement of purpose but there they
are going to want to see uh that you
have you know they're going to want
you it will be harder to make that case
right so if you have a background like
myself if you have a a degree in English
literature or something like that and
then you apply and you say I've taken a
couple Coursera courses they may not
feel that that rises to the level uh of
being eligible to take some of these
courses because they're quite hard and
and something like cs229 you're going to
be writing mathematical proofs right
you're going to really need to
understand not just how to apply
probability but really you know you'll
need to understand the theory underneath
it and so they do want to make sure that
you can be successful in these classes
and so uh there there can be instances
where those kinds of things can count
for it but I think if you came in with
completely self-taught they might not
it's it's always up to the department
they might not approve that or they need
a little bit more from you to sort of
feel confident that you'll be successful
so an example of what might be so maybe
you have an undergraduate degree in
mathematics but you didn't have
programming and so you took a few sort
of Coursera programming courses they
might feel comfortable letting you in to
to kind of the first course to see how
how it goes uh in in that example
because they'd feel confident that you
have at least a strong grounding in some
of those uh requirements if you do need
if you don't have that background you're
interested in kind of starting and
building it up we do offer graduate
certificate certificates and programming
and Foundations in computer science and
those are again pretty rigorous classes
um expect to spend 15 to 20 hours a week
on those as well and they'll walk you
through the the basics of programming as
well as discrete math probability theory
for computer scientists
um and and other courses like that and
those would be a strong Foundation
getting ready for uh for for these
programs
um Petra were there other questions that
you saw uh
I think there was also a question if you
can kind of mix and match the
professional courses and the graduate
courses like if you start with one of
them like does it prevent you from
taking the other courses in the future
great great question it does not and I
think we're seeing more and more people
opting into switching between two of
them so officially for the professional
program you can count one graduate
course towards it and the the idea there
is that if there's an elective because
the graduate courses is as you'll see in
has we have more offerings than than you
have in the professional program partly
because we can we work with the
department offer what's available on
campus
um and so that that is official that
where in terms of the other way uh where
you cannot count a professional course
cannot count for academic credit uh but
you can certainly mix and match right so
maybe there's there's a version where
you don't want to take the class A
Certain class uh in the graduate program
either because it's going to be too too
much time or too much work and yeah you
can take it as a professional uh as well
um
I see let's see there's a question about
uh there's a really good question here
about you having completed a master's
degree a while ago and the math
prerequisites
so some of this is is depend on you if
say you completed your master's degree
10 years ago and you did all the
prerequisites at that at that point um
you know they're they're probably I
can't guarantee it but they probably say
okay yeah this person did linear algebra
as a master student uh you know 10 years
ago they have the foundations now you
know that you did it 10 years ago and
and you probably don't remember it that
well so it would really be important uh
that you review that material before you
jump into the class
um because you're going to want to have
it somewhat up to date now most of these
classes do begin with some review or
have sessions that that for those of you
who need a review it's not just you it's
a lot of the students might need a
review a brush up on linear algebra
probability or statistics and so they do
usually begin with some level of review
but if it's been 10 years you might want
to be able you might want to set aside
some time before beginning the class to
do a more in-depth review and that is
again a really good reason for going to
those course pages and taking a look at
in every single course I should say in
the Stanford artificial intelligence
graduate certificate every single one of
them has a course website so it's not
true of all the courses that we offer
through the uh for graduate credit but
it's true for those so I would take a
look at those course websites take a
look at the material some of them even
have like what they call problem set
zeros where they'll say look at this
problem Set uh if this material if you
feel comfortable with this material then
you should be okay in this class if you
don't then uh you you should you might
want to take a different class
um
so yeah so that that is you know that's
that it's a it's a great question you
want to make sure it's it's somewhat uh
up to date
um Petra were there other questions
before we move on to the professional
program
a little bit about logistics like is
there a deadline to apply uh is there
like deadline to kind of
cancel my registration like things like
that both great questions so yes so
there is every quarter there's a
deadline to apply for the coming quarter
so for fall the deadline to apply is
September 10th so if you want to apply
and enroll in a course and your
application isn't complete until you and
you know submit a request to enroll in a
course you'd want to do that in the next
uh what is that 12 days next roughly two
weeks
um then in for winter courses our
enrollment will open up I believe at the
end of October and you have until early
December to enroll for winter and then
the same thing right there are different
sort of enrollment periods usually about
six weeks for each quarter so enrollment
um opens about two months before a
quarter begins and it lasts for about
six weeks
um so that that's in terms of that in
terms of the logistics of of dropping
the class Etc so um when you enroll
um you you pay for the course and then
you can uh you can drop it
for a full refund up to the the day
before the courses begin so if the
courses begin on a Monday you have until
that Sunday to drop the course to email
us and say you know what I've looked
through the material and I'm just not
ready for it or you know very commonly
something like a project came up at work
and I know I you know I thought I had
all this time uh this fall and I don't
so I've got to drop the course that's
fine
once courses begin you have uh in most
quarters so autumn uh winter and spring
you have three weeks before the drop
deadline
and you have so you have three weeks
it's usually the end of the third week
up until the end of third week you have
until then to drop the course and if you
drop the course in those three weeks you
get a full refund minus a hundred dollar
processing fee right and so that's
really you know once the course starts
it's really important that you you go in
make sure you can access all all the
materials you look at that you look at
the syllabus you look at your work
schedule you work at your your family
schedule what vacations those guys are
things you're planning make sure
everything's going to work out look at
the exams Etc uh and then just make sure
that it's the right experience for you
and if it isn't then you let us know and
we can drop you
um it's important to say that's a pretty
hard deadline that that end of the third
week because it's not just our deadline
it's a university deadline right so
that's when all students have to drop
the course and this is maybe a a a
detail too far but just just to say it
is when you drop the course nothing will
show up on your transcript right it's
just you never it's essentially like you
never took the course
after that drop deadline
you cannot you're not eligible for a
refund and if you leave the course
um through there are some other ways you
can do it so a withdraw would be what
you would have to do if you withdraw
from the course it does show up on your
transcript as a withdrawal okay so it's
you'll still see the course I'll say a
withdrawal and then there are some other
things that aren't worth going into
detail at this stage but so again to
repeat the core idea here is up until
you know that the first that before the
first day of classes you can drop for a
full refund after the first day up
through the drop deadline which is
usually but not always the end of the
third week you can drop for a full
refund minus a hundred dollar processing
fee
this question before kind of talking
about a professional program how about
International students and are they
required to join the classes online when
they are happening
uh that's a great question so yes uh no
so the great question no most students
are not your the the way that this has
been sort of set up is the idea is that
most of you are are working
professionals and you would not be able
to join a lecture from 11 to 12. uh or
whatever time because even if you're
local in the in the Bay Area
um you know chances are you're working
from 11 to 12. so the expectation is
that you would not you would not have to
join the class live for the lectures now
again you're going to hopefully be able
to make some of the office hours
um uh because
those will some of those will be held
online because that's your opportunity
to talk real time with you know with the
TA or with the faculty member there will
also be discussion discussion boards
where you can post your questions
so the short answer is we have plenty of
international students who take these
classes and do so successfully uh in
most cases you do not need to join uh
you do not need to join the lectures uh
real time and so you can be flexible
about when you do it now it's important
to emphasize you still have to meet all
the deadlines so if there's an app if
there's a homework that's due that
Friday
at 5 5 p.m Pacific time you need to
submit it by 5 PM Pacific Time now I
don't know what time that might be where
you are but you need to make sure right
so you need to kind of handle that those
kinds of um time zone uh time zone
differences
um and as I said it can be a bit more
you know if you're an international
student and this is something you're
really interested in go in with that
just understand that there will be some
challenges because you will be in a
different time zone for most of the
students as well as the faculty member
um so uh you know it can be a challenge
you know if you post a question at your
time which is 1am here it may be a while
before an answer you get an answer just
because everyone's asleep here uh though
actually they're all you know computer
science graduate students actually
probably 1am is a great time who knows
um but so again the short answer is yes
if you're an international student this
absolutely can work for you you just
need to go in you know again being
really careful looking at that syllabus
looking at the deadlines looking at the
times and just being aware of that
um Petra any other questions that came
up
I think those were a key question
um those were the key question and maybe
we can move on to the professional
program and then come back I'm sure
there will be more questions coming up
uh over the next minutes
um yes
okay so let me now talk to you a little
bit more about AI professional program
so as Pax mentioned in the graduate
program we are offering the actual
graduate classes
along when they are happening right so
you'll be taking the actual graduate
class that is taught at Stanford which
Stanford faculty in our AI professional
program we use the same content but what
we do we try to make it a little bit
more flexible and manageable for our
professional audiences what does that
mean is that we try to lower the time
commitment a little bit so we are
finding the time commitment in the
graduate class is Maybe
20 around 20 hours per week it really
depends right like some people come with
uh with deep knowledge before some
people need more time to kind of catch
up so maybe like 20 to 25 hours a week
in the like 15 to 20 hours a week like
it really depends in the professional
program you're trying to take it down to
like 10 to 15 hours a week that's sad
it's still the same challenging content
the same challenging assignments but we
do few modifications uh we first like
work on the videos to make them
um kind of more streamlines we are not
watching the one and a half hour long
video
identifying the key assignments and key
elements that we should be covering in
the professional class so this might
mean that one or two assignments are
removed from the course from the
original class we never have final exams
we usually don't have uh final projects
as part of our classes but other than
that other than that the content is
basically the same
so you can see here like the the price
is a little bit lower the the time
commitment is a little bit lower and
what is important to say and as Pax
mentioned we actually offer some of the
classes as part of both programs so when
Pax was talking about cs224n natural
language processing with deploying I
will be talking about xcs224n natural
language processing with deep learning
which will include the same content but
we will have let's say only it's not
only but like we have five assignments
we don't have any final exam the final
project has been removed and it's only
included in the other class natural
language understanding so there are kind
of these like
small pieces that make make it a little
bit different while keeping the content
the same
you're able to take these classes
individually so if you are interested in
some specific subject only you're able
to join one class and you will
absolutely if you pass get a certificate
at the end if you choose to kind of get
the whole certificate you will be
completing three courses so energy
courses and a combination of three
courses and you will be getting
professional certificate and artificial
intelligence so we see people who are
coming and they are still not sure so
they might be starting let's say with
xcs221 artificial intelligence
principles and techniques and they are
more interested in kind of the whole
generative AI NLP field so they continue
with the NLP and the nlu course
afterwards but it's just kind of one
group of people we have a lot of people
who kind of mix and match depending on
their interests and schedules some
people are more more interested in kind
of the machine learning and
reinforcement learning area so all of
that is possible
in terms of again the specifics like me
kind of point out a few as I mentioned
directly based off set for graduate
level equivalence we use recorded
lectures so on the first day of the
class you're not waiting for this kind
of the videos to be released by week but
you already have access to everything
all the assignments all the course
content all the videos so you're able to
also work a little bit more ahead and
behind the schedule we also have a
little bit more flexible deadlines that
we allow you to sometimes like or
sometimes we always allow you to submit
later we have some light submission
deadlines and something like that really
trying to make it a little bit more
manageable for professional folks
we run these courses in 10 weeks cohort
so you still are getting kind of similar
intense very intense challenging
experience and generally I would say we
have around 120 Learners joining the
same class at the same time let's say so
if you're joining let's say cs221
artificial intelligence principles and
techniques you will likely be joined
like by a big group of people from all
around the globe who are interested in
the same class which gives some
opportunity in networking and like
getting to know folks who are working on
similar problems As You Are at work
as Pax was talking about like we still
have like mix of written and programming
assignments we don't have the final
exams in this case and in terms of
support we don't have teaching
assistants as in the graduate class but
we do hire industry experience course
facilitators who took the original
graduate class and also work in the
industry so they're also able to kind of
bring that industry experience into the
discussion so they are helping with the
subject matter uh with the content
relates to questions with folks we also
try to host group office hours for the
assignments depending on the course to
kind of give some sort of an
introduction and they are there to kind
of help you if you need to jump on
one-on-one color things like that all
that said it will still be challenging
and you're still it's kind of still your
responsibility to make sure that you
complete the assignments but we do hope
it is kind of provides you with an
option to get support you need like get
your questions answered the other aspect
we have slag that I would say is
generally very vibrant and very active
that people also classmates tend to help
each other course facilitators are there
so they're helping each other so it's
kind of we think uh like it's one of the
benefits of joining these courses
in terms of passing and
um like what is kind of the requirement
in terms of passing our courses are pass
fail which is something important to say
so when Pax was talking about you need
to get a specific grade because you're
getting graded in the graduate program
professional we don't give you great so
you're either passing and getting the
certificate or you're not passing and
not getting the certificate and you will
need 70 to pass
so again this gives you a little bit
more flexibility you see there are like
these like little pieces that all
together bring some flexibility in
making this happen but that said I don't
want to kind of pretend that these
classes are easy they are definitely
challenging and we know that you know
people actually sometimes like sweat a
lot while working on the assignments but
hopefully at the end it's rewarding and
they learn what they need to know about
the subject
and as I mentioned uh if you complete
three courses you will get a
professional certificate I took few
screenshots just to give you a little
bit more idea of what am I talking about
what does this all mean so this is an
example of a schedule uh for upcoming
class that is starting on September 11
NLP with deep learning so on the left
side and I'm realizing it's probably too
small but you see some kind of
suggesting pacing guide for the videos
that you are able to watch with
assignment deadlines coming up
um in this particular course the
assignments get more difficult as time
progresses so like you see the kind of
the first assignment deadlines are close
to each other then it gets far away
you're always able to to submit the
assignments late plus we have standardly
scheduled live calls such as kind of
assignment group office hours we have
calls like we try to always schedule
some industry related sessions that
would be talking a little bit more about
the applications in the industry we
always try to have one q a at least with
the faculty we can never promise that
because we are very busy but we always
try to do that so they're also live
calls so it's not all just boring like
you watching the lectures behind a
computer we try to make it like more
active also including the slack
written assignments again just a
screenshot so for the written ones if a
class has a written assignment we
include some additional hints to
hopefully make it a little bit easier
but again we are not trying to make it
easy easy
so this is what you might see but uh the
questions are again from the original
graduate level content you might be
required to like write some written
analysis and proofs which some people
don't really appreciate after like you
know spending many years in the industry
and coming back to this but like I must
say that not all classes included this
we have some classes that are more kind
of
programming heavy some of them are kind
of mix and match depending on the
original graduate class so as Pax
mentioned before and I will repeat it
now and probably once again we recommend
that you take a look at the Stanford
online YouTube channel where we usually
are able to share all the resources kind
of publicly for free in terms of the
video content
and also The Graduate lectures or
graduate classes offer a lot of
materials like online so if you search a
class graduate class online you are able
to kind of preview some of the topics
that will be covered it can really give
you the best idea of what to expect like
what the assignments look like like what
is actually the subject about
programming assignments in the
professional class we develop Auto
graders for you so you're able to kind
of
locally debug like upload it get some
feedback being able to kind of improve
your score as you go
um so we see that this is very helpful
in terms of kind of debugging and making
sure you get to the higher score later
on and one big element is kind of the
whole Community course facilitators the
industry experience course facilitators
and all your classmates right because
you won't be the only person joining
this course uh from the industry or from
wherever you work so it's like a good
kind of I would say binding uh mechanism
to like get to know your classmates
yeah in terms of let me take a breath
and maybe take a quick look at the
questions but I will go back to the
product visits afterwards
Petra just a few questions or maybe
worth in terms of the projects if you
could talk a little bit more about those
those individual those group work is it
an option to do right away so if I go
back to the list of the courses only one
course
excuse to do for you natural language
understanding currently offers a project
work the rest will be kind of a
combination usually of written and
programming assignments the project work
in nlu class is open-ended so it's not
like sometimes our competitions like has
this kind of predefined project that you
follow and like you have very specific
requirement that you need to write down
and like very specific answer you need
to get to like it's not like that like
you can really pick a topic based on
your own interest
and we also encourage people to work in
teams for this particular class so you
can form a team up to three people and
work on the project together so you know
the subjects and content really depends
we have people working on
predicting
um
stock prices uh based on sentiment
analysis of something we have people
really interested in recipe development
based on what they have in the fridge
like it's really like depends so those
are kind of the two subjects that came
to my mind but like the other people
work on different things uh depending on
their interest
but I see a bunch of questions about a
prayer visits also so I will jump on
over here
for professional program there is a
short application where we will
basically ask you to tell us about your
Proficiency in these three things so we
will ask you about your name where do
you work why are you interested but then
we will be mainly covering the
prerequisites and we expect that you
have professional in Python all the
classes require python because that's
basically the main class main
programming language we are using
College calculus linear algebra
probability Theory those are the same
reasons as Pax was mentioning before for
the graduate class especially for the
written assignments but also for coding
it will be daily required so if you did
take
uh classes like this maybe 20 years back
when you were in a grad school it's
totally okay but we do recommend that
you kind of try to get back to it before
you join the first course uh because
some of this might be like really kind
of foreign after some time I also saw a
lot of questions coming up about oh I
took
um data science or like I took math for
machine learning or like classes like
that or like deep learning
specialization or machine learning
specialization like different classes
that are available online it's totally
fine like you don't need to have degree
in computer science to join these
classes absolutely not but we still ask
you to kind of identify how you meet
this criteria so it might be I took
these three classes
I feel confident great if you just tell
us you feel confident we will likely not
accept you so we just ask you for a
little bit more context but you don't
need to have kind of a formal degree in
computer science to join these classes
we have people from the July variety of
backgrounds and I talked about industry
but we also get a lot of kind of
students in their final year of grad
school that would like to kind of take a
class in this subject we get a lot of
professors who would like to kind of get
familiar with the subject we get a lot
of people who are startup owners who are
already retired but I would like to kind
of keep up with all the trends that are
going on so it's really like the the the
the the profiles of people who are
joining these programs really varies
and I think we just have kind of a
summary after this but I will go and
take a look at the questions and maybe
packs if you saw some questions that I
can help answering let me know
um I I think there are a lot of
questions about what's covered in a
particular courses and where's a good
place to start and so my you know a
couple things we'll say is one again a
lot of this material especially on The
Graduate side and again the professional
courses are based on the graduate
certificate a lot of this is is publicly
available and so you can in many cases
so for instance um one of the more
popular courses is is cs224 and natural
language processing you can see I think
we have three years of lecture videos
available on YouTube and and some of
those lecture videos are what are used
in the in the professional certificate
so you can go look at those lecture
recordings to get a sense of the quality
of the recording and then you can go to
the course website for cs224n and take a
look at what the assignments are and
what the pacing is for the for the
graduate side I think that we know it's
a big investment so we don't you know
please do take take some time take a
look at those courses a lot of this
material is available publicly if you're
not sure if you're interested in The
Graduate certificate but you're not sure
that would definitely be the place to
start you could also take a professional
course and see how that is because
you'll know that the the you know they
are very closely based on The Graduate
certificate they're less expensive uh
you don't get any kind of academic
credit but you will learn the material
and you'll get a sense of whether you
feel like that was you know you would be
ready to take a graduate course
um we did get some questions about the
master's degree in computer science at
Stanford so there is just a a computer
science master's degree there is a way
to do that on a part-time or online
basis right now for computer science you
can only pursue the master's degree
online if you're in the U.S they're not
accepting International people who are
going to live internationally it is the
same application so it's not through us
you just apply to the department and you
would indicate that you're interested in
pursuing it on a part-time basis the
master's degree is you know hugely
competitive they get thousands and
thousands of applications for a very
limited number of spots they generally
do not have informational sessions and
and I would just go to the computer
science website to see you know to find
out more about what their application
requirements are
um and and more about their program
there uh so the the it should we should
I do want to emphasize the The Graduate
certificate or computer science classes
taken as a non-degree student do not in
any way guarantee you to get into the
Master's Degree
um you know you'll have a Stanford
transcript that you can submit as part
of your application uh but that that's
not a guarantee a lot of obviously
Stanford students apply for those
master's degrees as well
um Petra did you see um I'll add one
more thing for the graduate courses as
well uh for international students who
are taking it abroad you obviously do
not need to have a Visa or anything in
the U.S you can just take it from abroad
uh you know uh and and you you won't
need to submit you don't need a US Visa
because you're not studying in the US
you're studying from wherever you are
um
and so there's a question you know in
terms of transferring AI certificate
programs graduate programs towards other
master's degrees that'll depend on the
Master's Degree um you'll I would take a
look at the the master's degrees
requirements often you know the specific
questions about management science and
engineering
um you know that often there will be
electives that are you know any 200
level class in the School of Engineering
or something like that but I would I'm
not familiar enough with the elective
requirements for management science and
engineering to be able to answer that
specifically so I just go to the the the
master's degrees
programs and and take a look to make
sure that these classes would count
towards that
um I saw a few questions about kind of
the required sequence or where to get
started
um
also there were a few so I will follow
up on that there were also a few
questions like can you help me with uh
kind of career transition or can you
help me with kind of research
opportunities since we are daily focused
on education and we are part of Stanford
University we can't really do that so
unfortunately like the answer to those
questions would be no I saw that coming
up a few times so just wanted to clarify
that but let me kind of cover the first
question like I saw it also multiple
times where to get started or like what
is a good sequence
I would say it really depends on your
kind of prior knowledge experience and
the interest in the professional program
you can really mix and match and you can
also just take one course if you want so
that hopefully already gives you some
flexibility if you are really unsure you
might have the right prerequisites but
still like you're not really familiar
with the whole area of AI machine
learning we generally recommended the
xcs221 artificial intelligence
principles and techniques is a good
course to start with because it covers a
lot of subjects that are also covered in
the other classes so it's a busy course
there are six assignments in that a
combination of coding and rhythm uh but
in you know like on the other hand it
really gives you kind of a good overview
so if you feel like this is something
that might be valuable I would recommend
to get started with that
again it depends especially this year we
are getting a lot of people interested
in XCS to do for nnxcs to do for you the
NLP class and an Lu class
because all the generative Ai and like
everything that is going on in the
industry
that's sad like as we mentioned all
these classes have perfect visits uh so
just kind of be mindful of that so take
a look like what what might be the right
level of knowledge to know but if this
is kind of of your interest that you
would like to catch up like those might
be the courses you might want to
consider but I don't want to disrespect
any other classes xcs229 machine
learning and access to three for
enforcement learning those are really
good fundamental classes in these
subjects meaning that you really get the
depth and breadth of all both both of
these and generally like when we talk to
our faculty and we talk to our kind of
academic director Chris Manning about
why do these courses tend to be like
challenging why do people need to do
these like proofs and stuff like that it
really helps you better be back and like
being able to come up with your own
Solutions and like innovative ways how
to solve problems at work and we do
think there are some questions about
like competition right like how does
this compare to Google AI certificates
stuff like that we really try to help
you with really getting the deep
understanding because we really think
that Stanford adds the offer that you
know they can give you those other
people who were part of the development
of many of the algorithms they are
teaching so the dealer can give you the
Deep knowledge in both the graduate and
the professional certificate and then
you're really able to kind of take it
and being able to actually being more
let's say independent right like you're
not really restricted with the packages
that are of the Shelf
xcs224w machine learning with graphs
that's just coding a class there are
five coding assignments uh it's really
specific to kind of the graph different
sort of
um I don't even know how to explain it
as you can see like now the the real
subject matter expert but he would be
getting the real subject matter expert
from our people but like anything
supporting like the kind of the graph
neural networks and all these kind of
subjects you would be learning about in
this class the Deep multitask in meta
learning that's the last class and the
latest class we added to the portfolio
uh that goes really Beyond I would say
like much far ahead of all of these it's
a new class also thought at Stanford by
Chelsea Finn and she's trying to
basically teach you also like how how to
make also like algorithms thing out of
the box and like out of kind of the
tasks they have been able to resolve in
the past so really again like more
Innovative but again like this class
especially more challenging if you are
looking for something to get started
with I would say the first AI principles
and techniques it's a good class
two two four n natural language
processing with deep learning is a good
class
229 machine learning is a good class if
you would like to kind of step ahead and
take the other classes afterwards but
again it's like fundamental in its
nature so there's a lot of kind of depth
and breadth of the material and I'm
talking so much so I will pause and
packs any other questions
no I think you you answer a lot of them
that have come up and again uh there are
a lot of questions of where to start or
if you're not ready for for these kinds
of classes
um you know again Stanford online our
website uh that there are a lot of other
off there are a lot of other options
that are listed there that are not as
advanced so uh Petra mentioned uh the
Deep learning uh specializations through
Coursera we have an AI in healthcare
through Coursera that I think is more uh
more entry level
um and then there are other graduate
courses that you can take that are are
uh you know something like the the
introductory programming or or computer
science classes cs106 A and B is what
they're they're called I saw a question
whether 106a would be adequate for these
it would not be that would not be enough
programming background for for a lot of
these
um so you can take some of those
um
you know in addition we saw some
questions about specific subject matter
you know if you're an expert and you're
looking for you know the development a
particular area I would just recommend
looking through our catalog because you
would probably be able to identify and
answer that better than we can um I saw
a specific question about robotics there
is a graduate certificate in robotics
and and and autonomous systems uh and
there are a lot of courses around that
including and in fact part of the AI
graduate program is is the two course
introductory sequence on robotics uh
that that is uh taught here at Stanford
it's a it's two quarters uh and it's
meant to give people kind of a holistic
understanding of Robotics so you do a
little bit of everything from sensors
and gripping and and and
um and planning Etc so you you get a
kind of a sense of the whole robot uh so
that you know you can sense of how these
things integrate
um
there
it's here
um
in the air and we're seeing again
specific things for for so Petra went
through I think for the professional
program for the graduate program it's
largely the same we generally don't
recommend starting with cs229 as your
very first Stanford Graduate course
um just because it is a very hard course
and so people are often caught off guard
by that
um we would recommend something like
cs221 or another you know it doesn't
have to be in the AI graduate
certificate you could start with another
one a lot of people like starting this
thing like cs109 which is not
unfortunately offered this fall but is
one on it's called probability for
computer scientists and it goes over the
probability but it's it's again with an
eye towards computer science I think it
does even get a little bit of the
machine learning towards the end
um and it's it's a good course uh for
considering that um
we see some questions about
um as well about uh financial aid
unfortunately uh in generally speaking
there isn't financial aid for non-degree
students and I don't believe we offer
financial aid on the professional side
either
we don't but oh let's satellite
are available
like you know the costs might be too
high for some folks uh and you know we
appreciate that so
um I would recommend you take a look at
Stanford YouTube stand for online
YouTube and also the resources yeah
yeah so there's a lot that's available
out there um
it's here
um
uh I see so there's a similar question I
think
um uh Petra for for the professional
program you do not need to be
continuously enrolled either so I I
don't know is there a specific period of
time in which you need to complete all
three courses in order to be awarded the
certificate
um there's no timeline so you can Relay
schedule or time schedule your time as
you need and I just remember there was
one more question about scheduling so if
you go to the artificial intelligence
professional program page you will see
the upcoming classes but we generally
run all classes twice to three times a
year depending on the class so like if
you don't see it it doesn't really fit
your schedule you can come back and take
it at later time and since there's no
deadline to complete and you don't need
to be continuously enrolled it really
depends on like what kind of what's
going on uh outside of of the education
for you
and Petra I'm going to jump ahead here
back to the um
we uh actually oh sorry I should
actually Jump Ahead to the um
uh I just want to go back to the
comparison slide so let me pull that up
um and because we're we're reaching the
end here a couple other questions uh
that came up so
um in terms of the if you are enrolled
in a graduate course or a professional
course so for for The Graduate
certificate for all the graduate courses
that we offer
we have a student orientation every
single quarter so that will be happening
the week before courses start and
courses will be starting uh on September
25th I believe
it's Tuesday it's a Tuesday it's I think
it's the 25th of the 26th uh and so
that's when those course will be
starting the week before that we will be
sending out an invitation to everyone
who's already enrolled uh even if your
enrollment hasn't reached final approval
we'll still invite you to an orientation
that's where we'll go over more specific
logistics for getting ready for the fall
quarter for the professional program
each course I believe has an orientation
is that correct uh Petra um yes correct
so you'll get an orientation for each of
those courses before you begin
um
and then let's hear in terms of cost
yeah so the graduate courses are
fourteen hundred and fifty six dollars
per unit and most of them are three to
four units so you're looking they're
they're five to seven thousand dollars
of course they're they're expensive it's
full tuition for the professional
certificate Petra is it currently
Seventeen hundred and fifty dollars per
course is that correct correct yeah so
750 per course and again that's another
reason for us to try to offer these in
different ways for The Graduate
certificate in the graduate courses is a
non-degree student we still have to
charge kind of full Stanford tuition
which we know is a lot uh the
professional we can offer at a much uh
lower rate for those of you who do I you
know we often don't know
um specifics around company policy so I
would reach out to your own organization
I see that question about what are what
are kind of reimbursements that's
usually happening at the company level
so I'd reach out to whoever you're
learning development officer is or HR
and see what kind of uh you know what
kind of what kind of reimbursement they
might offer sometimes they offer for
both programs sometimes they only offer
it for the for the credit bearing
programs so
um
I think uh I think that's probably uh
we've gotten through most of them we may
not have gotten through all them we
apologize
um we will you know we'll have another
session like this in the future and
again if you've enrolled we'll have
orientations uh they'll a recording of
This will be sent out after uh in about
a week or two so you'll be able to watch
and if you missed it and we will also
have it on YouTube and again I'd
recommend this kind of ending this is
you know I would really we know it's a
big investment in time and money so we
highly recommend you go out you look at
the the the course pages that we have in
our catalog but you also just look at
the the actual um course websites for a
lot of these graduate course pages and
just see what the material is see if
that's what you're interested in and
then go to our YouTube channel and watch
a lot of the lecture videos you can get
a lot out of them and uh learn uh learn
a lot there
uh so will Petro is there anything last
minute that you wanted to add
maybe only if you have a question and we
didn't get to the answer we really
apologize we are really doing our best
on the kind of the back end of it with
the whole team but we will post uh
mailing list that you are welcome to use
if you have any kind of follow-up
questions for us
uh and let me make sure that we post it
and the last thing as you're you're
getting that posted is just the for the
graduate courses for fall quarter
enrollment is open right now uh and it
will close September 10th so you have
about 12 days if you're interested uh in
submitting an application and a request
to enroll in one of those courses uh
Petro are all the I think all the AI
professional courses are currently open
for enrollment they all start at
different times so what's the next
course that's starting on Wednesday and
sorry in the AI the graduate courses
will start as I said I believe it's
Tuesday I think September 25th or the
26th I should just look that up right
now
artificial intelligence principles and
techniques might be potentially a good
fit like agility pens but that course is
starting October 2nd if you want to kind
of ride the whole NLP uh surfing Journey
this year xcs224 and NLP with deep
learning is starting on September 11th
so kind of
you know like kind of shortly uh you've
only need to kind of apply if you're you
don't have an application on file so we
recommended you get started with the
application early and we did post the
email if you have more questions so
please don't hesitate to reach out to us
if we didn't get to your question we
still apologize but we'll make sure to
get to your email afterwards
thank you everyone for joining us uh we
look forward to hearing from you or
seeing you in a class in the future
thank you everybody have a nice day